Hello, and welcome to another
episode of GDL-IL, GDL Israel.
Today we're going to
do some [INAUDIBLE]
things.
We'll start with checking out
how we could run NodeJS on
Google infrastructure on Google
Cloud, and we'll use of
course Compute Engine
to do that.
And later, we'll see how easy
it is to use NodeJS in order
to run things like fetching
data from other
sources on the web.
It might be another API, in our
case we took a different
set of APIs, not directly Google
ones, just to show you
the power of getting information
from any open API
that you have out there.
And then, using Google Sheets
in order to upload this API,
this data, and then later on
of course using it and
leveraging it inside
Google Sheets.
The nice thing or the nice theme
that is connecting all
the dots in this episode
will be JavaScript.
And we have JavaScript
on the server side.
And of course, we'll use
NodeJS to execute it.
And then, we'll have JavaScript
as the scripting
language of Google Docs and
Google Apps that allows you to
do clever, sophisticated things
on the information, on
the data that you already
fetched and put in your Google
Sheets in our case.
So without further ado, let me
just share my screen with you.
And maybe today, I'll just share
my old desktop so I can
jump quickly.
Or maybe it would be wiser, I'll
just try to go through
this little blog post that just
summarizes all the things
that we're going to touch on.
The blog post is live as of 10
minutes ago, so feel free to
go and check it out.
And of course, I'll put links
to this blog post on the
footnotes of this show on the
developer.google.com site.
So feel free, you don't need
to write anything.
Basically, what we're going
to show here is
the ability to go.
And in this case, I just choose
Yahoo Finance API just
because I got lots of questions
on how to use it and
leverage it from inside
Google Sheets.
And here in the example you
[INAUDIBLE], basically Yahoo
allows you to do things like
get a certain URL.
Let me make all the
fonts much larger.
And then, if you put in
here, I put Netflix.
But you could put any ticker.
And after you put a ticker, you
have a set of let's say
parameters, or it's more
crypting keys that will fetch
the right information
that you want.
And once you are clicking
on it, basically you're
downloading a CSV file that you
can later on work with it.
In our case, we want to
do something nicer.
And basically, to take even
farther this approach of
getting data, getting
information, and then putting
it into good work, into good
usage inside of Google Sheets.
So what I did here is after
you've installed NodeJS, and
if you remember correctly, I
have an episode in the past
here on this [INAUDIBLE]
how to install NodeJS on Compute
Engine in less than
five minutes.
So just go search
it and do that.
That's the first step
that you need to do.
But after you install NodeJS,
basically you just need those
three packages.
And luckily for us, the
community around NodeJS is
holding a very large set of
libraries and frameworks and
abilities, basically already
made wheels for us.
So we don't need to reinvent
the wheel again.
And in this case, I just choose
those three libraries.
One is the request model
that just lets you do
work easily with URLs.
Basically, we're using a very
easy way of fetching the
information with
a get request.
But once you install it,
basically you have all the
different possibilities of doing
authentication, doing
OAuth, post, and all the
good things that you'll
want to do later on.
So it's good thing to have right
at the beginning of a
new project that is going to do
something interesting with
this API that is being
fetched over HTTP.
Then, I put cheerio.
It's a cool name.
And for us, it's basically
jQuery on the server side.
So the ability to work with that
dollar sign that we all
love, and just to be able to
have these CSS selectors to
get the right piece of
information from this or that
location in the DOM.
Very easy to do.
So that's why I use this one.
And last but not least, just to
make our life easier when
we're going to integrate and
upload and edit and update our
information, let's just leverage
again already built
model that's letting us just
work with Google Spreadsheets.
Having those three pieces of
code in place, our code will
be really, really short.
So in these three lines, we're
just fetching the models so we
could work with them later.
And then, of course, we have
those few parameters that we
want to keep as global
to our script.
I highly recommend you to remove
them, as in line 19
it's written here.
Not black and white, but clearly
enough, you want to
remove them from the
global scope.
In this specific, simple case
I just left it there.
But probably the first thing
that I'll do tomorrow morning
would be just to remove them
from the global scope, make
sure that I'm encapsulating them
inside an object so when
this project will get bigger and
bigger and not just live
as a gist, we'll be able to have
all the best practices of
software development.
And we want [INAUDIBLE]
so quickly.
So the basic constants here
are just the ticker, and
probably it would be wiser just
to put it as a variable
so that the user will enter
from the script itself.
Later on, just the end point.
And in your case, it might
be Google Cloud endpoint.
It might be any other API that's
letting you just fetch
information over
HTTP or HTTPS.
And then, just two actually
arrays that are letting us
have the keys, or mainly the
metadata on the data that
we're going to fetch, and
the details themselves.
Then, we have a few functions
that we're using.
sheetReady, we'll touch
on it later.
And in this one,
basically we're
just calling the request.
So after we're fetching
the URL.
Here, you can see that first
and foremost I just want to
see that everything came
back correctly with
status code of 200.
If it's 400 or 500 or other
things, I want probably to
just notify the user.
And in this case, I'm just
loading into cheerio the body.
And then nicely enough, I have
this dollar sign that
I could work with.
And in this case, I'm just
choosing one table that's
containing all the
information.
And then, I'm getting all the
tds in this table into my
array, the keys.
And I'm doing just the same
thing on a different class
name and fetching
all the details
into a different array.
Once I do those two things,
all I need to do now is
basically just of course letting
ourselves know that we
have the right information
in place.
And we'll run the script
in a minute.
And then, I want to upload it.
So look how easy is
the API itself.
I call it.
I'm creating a new one.
Basically, I already
created one.
But here, I'm just creating or
calling the constructor of
this object that here it's
called spreadsheet.
And the debug information is
just for us right now.
Actually, I see that we
have two lines of it.
So I need to remove one.
Here, of course, you want to put
your credentials, probably
your Gmail address and
then your password.
And very important, the sheet
name and the worksheet.
So both of them need to be here
so we know which sheet we
are going to update.
And then we're calling, in the
callback after this, returning
the sheetReady method.
And if we scroll back to this
method, basically you could
see that it's a very,
very simple one.
We're adding to the spreadsheet
on the top.
So it will be at column one, row
one, and then column one,
row two, the attribute
and the value.
And then, we're just going
to iterate and
just in those arrays.
And luckily for us, any looping
here will just call
our object, the spreadsheet,
and will add an array.
We're giving it the
starting point.
And once I get the started
point, all we need to do is
just attach the array, and all
the information will be there.
And of course, we're sending
all the information in one
batch and getting
the response.
Here, probably you want to
notify the user that
everything is done correctly
and is in the good hands of
Google Cloud.
So all the data is now saved.
And of course, if something
wrong happens, just
communicate it back.
That's all the script.
So you could see here that at
the bottom, there's nothing
more than it.
And now, we could check or let
me show you how you could
quite easily run this script.
So let's see again
in this window.
This is my terminal.
I'll make the font
even bigger, and
even one step bigger.
And what you can see here is
that I'm calling node with the
fetch example that
we have here.
And once I'm running it,
quite quickly we're
going to Yahoo API.
We're fetching the
information.
Here, the console log
just making sure--
actually, it's from here--
that I'm fetching
the information.
And you can see that in this
case, for instance, the key
would be the market cap.
And then, I have the overall
value of the company.
And again, and again, lots
of other parameters.
And then, when I'm wanting to
upload it to Google, I got a
log in error.
And this is because all I have
there right now are the to
dos, and not my real
credentials.
But I highly encourage you to
fork the gist that we just
showed and just put your
credentials and work with it
and see how fluidly
it's working.
The other beauty is that you
could take this code that we
ran, and let me just again
share with you
that snippet itself.
We could actually see it here.
And this code, with very few
changes, will work from Google
App, Google Sheets as well.
So if you don't want even to
have the ability or the
efficiency of running this
simple script inside Node, you
could do the same
from JavaScript
that will run in Sheets.
And that's another benefit for
the ones that don't want to
work with a Node instance.
However, I highly encourage you
to check Compute Engine
and to check the ability to run
with NodeJS because the
performances will be
much, much better.
And if you want to do something
more than just
putting a simple example like
that, you want some heavy
lifting on the server side, some
data manipulation, some
things that you do want
a strong server side.
NodeJS on Compute Engine will
give you those benefits.
And it's highly recommended
to check it out.
So if we have any, questions
right now is
that the right time.
Let's see here.
Let's see if in the
chat we have some.
I don't see any question
right now.
So if you have later on any
questions, +GreenIdo on G+ or
GreenIdo as one word
on Twitter.
Both will work quite nicely.
Happy hacking, and be strong.
Bye-bye.